for showrunners you spoke to incredible
names in the industry and a lot of them
said they had a compulsion to do it even
though at times they lack sleep it
interfered with personal relationships
but they kept going and he almost
couldn't stop what do you think was the
reason is that something that's a
statement about sort of the creative
process that people don't want to let go
of things no matter what it's costing
them because they're so enthralled with
the outcome um I think it's a function
of the job as well to a certain extent I
mean you you kind of have to work those
errors because you're on a schedule and
you're on a budget and you have to
deliver an episode to air at a given
date if you don't do that that cause can
end up costing millions of dollars you
can throw the whole network schedule
into disarray so it's a combination of
they want to do the best work that they
could possibly do so everything is kind
of given as much time and attention as
it possibly can be but it's also a
function of just we have to produce a
show you know which is the great mix
between art and commerce that they
they're constantly kind of you know
battling against I think a little bit
anything to add it like being a parent
isn't it you know they're they're under
immense pressure from all sides and it's
like you know you get these plates
spinning at a certain rate and if you
drop one they all fall so I feel like
there's the degree of that where they
have to keep going like sharks though if
they stop swimming they'll die to some
extent not to compare them to sharks but
you know I think that once you get
entrenched into this methodology and
this type of work environment that it's
very hard to take yourself out of it and
relinquish that I wouldn't say control
but relinquished the the relinquished of
control because who else is going to do
it better than you are when you you have
created this cohesive vision for this
piece of effectively corporate art that
has to be on time and you know it
requires the immense effort
and talents of hundreds you know
sometimes thousands of people it's a
lots of manage so you've got to stay on
top of it all one of your show runners
mentioned there's a hundred percent
burnout rate that people in their early
to mid 50s eventually say no I'm done
what do you think is the personality
type that's attracted to this not just
the creative person everybody comes here
well armed with a script in their life
story and they think oh this is going to
be it but it takes a lot to really
maintain what 15 hour days sometimes
seven days a week yeah I think you have
to be pretty driven and I think you have
to be not afraid to piss peeve I can say
that is to piss people off because it's
very important that you come in and be
very clear about this is my show this is
the way we're going to do things you
have answers for people when they ask
you questions it's very important to
have answers and to be making decisions
all the time and people need to you know
be convinced that what you're telling
them is the right way to go so you need
to be very you know you need to be very
certain in your own vision of show when
you starting off and very driven with it
so for people who who might be want to
be people pleasers maybe a little bit
and want to get on with everybody I
think that's a much harder sell to be a
show runner with that kind of
personality type you need to be not
afraid to kind of annoy people to get
what you want out of them you know so I
think that's definitely one of the
traits anyway
you